there's dangerous this I have always  known look at what power has given me  since I invaded Paris I found myself  thinking what youth is power you see the  problem with power is said the more you  have  the more of us wanted and in my world  Pawel can only truly be built with blood  only fools believe they can live forever  by avoiding the fight  I embrace the idea of that will I get  into fella  power is dangerous these are the words  of the gods but that power that danger  is everything it lives in an army that  will protect my people and my room my  son I'd like to see has become the  bravest of warriors and listened  silently to the ramblings of men those  who dream of danger may awake to death  but life must be lived to the fullest  before it is over I embrace the idea of  life and death for I am not the one in  charge of my fate the gods have already  written my story  victory or FAL ha